tu d'un fleuron se découvre que sean
penn est assis au premier rang
à chaque faille et assure aux miracles
non on joue mieux que ce à quoi je peine
en première chaney sous charles
il était visiblement attiré par la jeune
comédienne
n'y tenant plus il se précipite sur
scène vont la rejoindre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
antoine aimerait bien que florent
florence avait des tas de choses
extrêmement drôle way prévu mais ce
qu'on s'était dit sean penn ne sera pas
assez ridicule je devais lui faire ma
danse de la séduction que je suis folle
voilà j'ai répété quatre heures il
fallait que je fasse cette dose de la
séduction est à présent antoine est vrai
bien que florence finissent par remettre
le césar mais évidemment florence
exécutent leurs vestes ou itunes
[Applaudissements]